multiple streams of income will not get
you rich it's not too fast this way when
the quit is when you stop loving it and
I think people just need to taste more
you need to try more I love that they're
cheating and I'm not
[Music]
[Applause]
then we have to Indianapolis
are we ready let's go what do you got
when you first started on YouTube and on
a video was the detection or was it
something I know I it was a strategy
given you came with passion or was it
passionately beginning so here's the
thing I think the acid test should be do
I want to do it again so don't go into
relationship trying to get married on
the first date might be a mistake maybe
it works to some people but for most
might be a mistake the acid test is do I
want to go back for a second date so
when I first did video I sucked right
brutal go watch it the whole history is
there I used to have to have my sister
come in focus
press record leave the room because I
couldn't do it with her in the room I
couldn't speak with her in the room
right I have I've had to fight the
judgment issues myself along the way
right so these strategies I've used
myself to get more comfortable but I
didn't I didn't love video I know that
like I had to do this thing for the rest
of my life I went and I said this is
cool yeah I like this I want to do it
again that was fun I mean it totally
sucked but that's ok I can probably make
it better the next time
and use that as your acid test and I
think people just need to taste or you
need to try more that's why the action
is so important you get an idea for
YouTube go make a youtube video oh I
only have audio who cares like put up a
picture and do it and see if you liked
it right it's like people who say that
how do you know if you like sushi or not
you're not gonna think your way through
it you might say oh well rice I don't
know and raw fish sounds nasty and okay
but just go try it and see we're
thinking too much so you try it and see
and then you see did I like it I kind of
liked that sushi place okay I'll go back
I'll do that again and then sushi
becomes your favorite food right so you
say yes to everything and then just see
if you want to go back and do it again
things like that but at what point is
you know for business cash flow is the
oxygen and what time is it like that
you're like I've been patient enough and
at this point it's gotta be delusion
that my company is making no money we're
not enough money it is turning itself it
might be kinda move on I think you need
to flip patience and impatience for most
people I think you need to have patience
for the results but be impatient with
yourself like today has to matter like
whatever is on your list are you proud
of your work today I'm accomplishing
those things and if not then tomorrow
make it double like make it count today
has a massive impatience for the effort
you're putting in daily but then having
patience with the results when the quit
is when you stop loving it and that may
mean you have to go get a job for a
period of time just to make cash will
happen but you're still doing your thing
because you can't breathe without it
right like his singing may not take off
to make him money yet so he has to go
work at ups for the next three years but
like I say I say that I say that because
Danny Danny came from ups a hates it but
don't don't stop singing like there's
still the realities some people go
hardcore and like no I'd rather be
homeless and still doing my thing and if
that's you great do that but if you need
to have you know a house or an apartment
or whatever it is and that me mean you
have to take on a job but just don't
stop doing your thing because otherwise
the regret will eat you up because
you'll be a hundred and looking back and
say man I could have done more I could
have done it but I just went to go work
for the man forever and you end up
hating your life so taking a step back
is okay but just don't go go to zero as
long as you love it as long as you love
it you have to find a way to keep going
and as soon as you stop loving it at
least for me I'm out like if I stopped
liking making top ten videos I would
stop forget y'all I'm out right like I
love you but I'm I'm out right and I'll
go do something else because you can't
create great things from a place of of
being forced to do it and it happens to
a lot of entrepreneurs you end up buying
yourself a job something worked you
liked it it was great and then you
evolved
but your business didn't evolve because
what was successful for you is now the
chains for you to move forward and you
keep end up doing that same thing that
you hate and now you've grown up here
and there's this huge disconnect and
you're unhappy you should quit sooner on
those things and go off and chase that
dream or evolve your business my
business is always reflection of me
before my youtube channel I had a
website you guys fire an ogee enough for
my website staff but at a website I had
I had a hundred thousand pages on my
website I had five thousand people
writing from my website and I turned it
off overnight
and said I'm done with this turned off
revenue had eight people on my team
moved them all over to YouTube and I'm
gonna do this now because it was
starting to drain me as soon as you feel
that you have to evolve it or move on
that's a personality thing like how do
you quit smoking
do you just quit as you go Nicorette
there's options right I think for me I
would much rather have a side hustle
with my job and then write all into one
big thing because I feel like you know I
was an entrepreneur
fifteen streams of income just because
they want to get rich
multiple streams of income will not get
you rich it's not too fast this way
take one and kick acid that thing yeah
if he's tries to go from singing to then
snowboarding and videoing and whatever
he'll learn he'll earn a lot of little
dollars but he'll never get rich even
now my Instagram I'm just getting into
Instagram people try to do everything so
you're you're on all the social networks
and then you suck on all of them and
you're just posting everywhere but it's
not quality and then you wonder why you
don't get results because you're trying
to do 20 things at the same time so
you're gonna suck so for like for social
would say have an account on each and
just listen so if somebody tweets you
you can respond to them and say thank
you and acknowledge them but you're not
posting hardcore in Twitter because
you're focused on Instagram and then go
crush Instagram and then build a team
under you for Instagram and then you can
go and do the next thing the people who
win get amazing at one thing and they
dominate and then you can look at
expanding to other things so I wouldn't
be thinking 15 streams of income but
then you have to be done with one like I
want to push I see I see these things as
Windows and the windows gonna close why
do I do three videos a day on YouTube
because right now my skill set with
where YouTube is at and my passion like
it's this magical thing that is amazing
and so I need to push as hard as I can
before it ends because it's gonna end
because that windows gonna close right
so in five years YouTube won't be the
fist the same anymore is gonna be
something new that pops up now the
skills I developed can be brought to
those other platforms the reason why I
can crush on Instagram is because of the
10 years on YouTube it's 80 percent the
same thing
there's just minor hacks and things that
you have to figure out what is 80
percent the same thing if the creative
content
No oh my god no no no this is actually
this is good because this is like I
think the one gold nugget that I've that
I've needed up I'm wanting to out my
injure just so much it's like you can do
real safe I look at this crypto oh I see
oh look it you know you can build a drop
shipping store over here then so it's
like but it but but what is it tied to
those are all this business models
there's lots of business models what is
it tied to what are you trying to
accomplish what's your passion was your
purpose right then is then you can
figure out what the best how is gonna be
but just doing a business because just
doing a podcast because 2019 is a year
of podcast you're gonna lose you can try
it you should taste it you should try
doing a podcast and try to no YouTube
channel but sticking with it just
because you think it's a good idea and a
good strategy you're gonna lose you have
to become the best podcaster and you can
and you can win and you can crush it but
to try to do podcast and then do your
own ico on the side and then drop
shipping and then garage sale flipping
and all that stuff right like there's
this understand that most of these
people are just fronting the number of
guys that I work with I see it on
YouTube because you know this is my
space is tons of guys who are buying a
whole bunch of fake stuff on Instagram
it's even worse the number of guys who
are ahead of me on YouTube on Instagram
that are that I'm chasing down the
number of fake followers they have is
insane and I'm getting hit up every day
with hey sixty bucks for a shout-out and
we're gonna get you you know thousand
new followers like you guys don't
understand I love the process
I want to chase these guys down and if I
don't know what's real and what's fake
I'm gonna hate myself I love that
they're cheating and I'm not it's the
best legit like I love that climb so
much and the amount of hate
hate but Matt of like laughs that I got
when when I started when I said I'm
gonna take Instagram more seriously and
I had 6,000 followers and I got like 1.5
million on YouTube and saying about this
guy sucks what are you doing I loved it
and then we go for six to seven ten to
20 to 40 100 right
I love the client I love that there's so
many people ahead of me like YouTube
when Gary slow down now Gary's headed me
on sub but behind on views I'm pumped
again like I love having the I love
having the competition when he slowed
down on on Christmas and on holidays
summer and Christmas he always slows
down and it pisses me off because his
team takes over and they're not as good
right so I I had I had a mental race
with him two million subscribers who
would get there first and like oh man
you know Gary's gonna take winter off
and August off and I'm pissed
cuz he was ahead of me but then he'd
slowed down so I passed him but it
wasn't a race it's like when it's easy
it's not you don't feel good I wanted
them at his best even if I lost right so
now he's ahead like I'm pumped again
that's great let's go taste it then yeah
once you find it though right like go
and taste it taste it trying try
dropshipping try ICEA whatever right and
just see like do I want to go back to it
but when you find it then blinders right
like I won because I did three videos a
day for five years on YouTube right
just focus crypto currency Bitcoin
Explorer awesome whatever great it's
gonna be the future right that's
happening but there's lots it's gonna be
the future everything is the future
great but so was so was YouTube so was
videos right and at some point will be
Evan in like VR coming at you or holo
lenses or whatever right but this is
that this is what I like playing in I
don't I hate real estate yeah I'm
telling you I'm anti real estate for me
personally I think I get a way higher
ROI on myself than invested in real
estate that's fine I love that you love
real estate it's amazing go crush any
real estate but if it's just a strategy
you're gonna get destroyed
just to make money you're gonna get
destroyed because people who love it
people who love it will eat you for
lunch come in on YouTube against me I'll
destroy you right but but like that's
how it is real estate is the same thing
in any field that's why you have to love
it so much to find your niche because
the people who are great at it and they
love it will destroy you from there and
everybody love the Junction's but I
hated me to their sides they never came
back to be anything like for anything so
like I need wonderful day you know how I
get so and I love that you're here this
is great
but listen making money is about making
money is about providing value yeah so
what's your goal and they're all
probably just doing ok what you can
bring insane value to making money as a
function of providing value the more
value you can bring to somebody the more
money you're gonna make
if you're always dabbling and trying
different things you never get great at
providing value so you'll have these
little things that give you tiny pockets
of money and then you feel like you
never have enough friend at the end of
the week where'd all that money go I
love that you're doing a non profit so
make your money to a providing value
right yeah so so real estate is just a
business model just like network
marketing just like anything it's just a
business model but if you don't love it
enough to get great at it you'll never
learn how to provide amazing value
doing it for the night but I wanna be
like the Boys and Girls Club on a
million that's like Marco from aa great
nonprofit is great you need to learn how
to make money first right and doesn't
mean that you wait till you're a
millionaire before you give back I love
giving back as we go a hundred percent
but you have to learn how to make money
in part of the process so so as an
example when I do in the tour we always
give away a seat to somebody who can't
afford to have the seat because that was
me
we're like I couldn't be able to afford
to come to this when I was first
starting out now we never say oh you
know this is the person who got the free
ticket right but that's part of the
contribution as always I always do
something that's free to help out and
give back but it's the more that you
grow a business the more you can
contribute back so many people who want
to give back and have a heart and like I
feel you find a percent but if you're
only doing that and you're not growing a
business you're not you're not gonna be
able to create anything that's really
lasting you just volunteering your time
so you build a business and in the
process of doing that have a portion ten
percent twenty percent whatever you want
that gives back to help in your
community don't be this hello great I
love it
can she be back but what are you gonna
build in in the process that's a
profitable business that's growing
because if you have 20 people working
for you and you're making lots of money
the amount of good that you can do is
amazing for having eight side hustles
and real estate while taking care of all
the kids five kids and like jobs and
everything is just gonna be bringing in
little bits we have to figure out where
can you put your passion against it
that's gonna provide like any of them
could work the ice cream truck could be
a million dollar business the candy
store could be a million dollar plus
business just that great of course not
so you got to find that thing right but
you're so busy doing all this stuff that
you don't like you haven't even found
spent time to find a thing that you do
so if I'm you I would even rather get a
job that I don't have to put that much
work into just to pay the bills and then
and then your extra time you're spending
on actually finding the thing that you
want to do that I'll start from and I
hate real estate but I love I mean
real estate it's great it's just not for
me so I hate real estate for me I don't
think it's the best investment model for
me but it's amazing and lots of people
made tons of money off real estate so
making these events happen is not a solo
effort I don't want to give a quick
shout-out to some of the people who
helped promote this event if you guys
like this video and you want to see what
I'm doing next in st. Louis go check out
their video right next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there